MORNING.
THE FAMILY OF BRIAN SITNICK
REFUSING TO SHAKE HANDS WITH
MITCH McCONNELL AND KEVIN
McCARTHY AT A CEREMONY HONORING
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AT THE
CAPITAL.
JOINING US NOW ARE HIS FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO LOVED HIM SO VERY
MUCH.
YOU SAW THEM IN THE VIDEO, HIS
MOTHER GLADYS AND BROTHERS KEN
AND GREG.
GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> WE'LL GET TO THAT AND WHAT
HAPPENED.
MOTHER TO MOTHER, TELL EVERYONE
ABOUT BRIAN.
>> BRIAN WAS VERY, VERY QUIET.
HE HAD A SENSE OF HUMOR THAT I
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT UNTIL --
THERE'S TWO OFFICERS THAT ARE
LIAISONS BETWEEN THE CAPITAL
POLICE AND US.
THEY TAKE US DOWN THERE AND
BRING US HOME.
THE STORY THEY TELL ABOUT HIM
WAS AMAZING.
HE WAS A VERY QUIET KID.
NEVER WANTED TO JOIN ANYTHING.
I PUT HIM IN T-BALL, TEN
MINUTES.
HE JUST DIDN'T WANT TO JOIN
ANYTHING.
THEN HE JOINED THE INTERNATIONAL
GUARD.
HE FOUND HIS WAY AND HE WAS
DOING WHAT WAS RIGHT FOR THE
COUNTRY.
>> WHAT DID IT MEAN FOR HIM TO
DO THAT?
>> HE WAS JUST -- HE JUST FELT
THIS -- HE WAS DEFENDING THE
CONSTITUTION, WHICH SHOULD BE
DONE.
>> MOM, I'M SO GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
GLAD ALL OF YOU ARE HERE.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT WHY
YOU DID WHAT YOU DID.
WHEN ASKED YESTERDAY ABOUT WHY
YOU DIDN'T SHAKE THE HANDS OF
McCARTHY AND McCONNELL, YOU SAID
THEY'RE TWO FACED.
YOU SAID YOU'RE TIRED OF THEM
SAYING HOW WONDERFUL THE CAPITAL
POLICE IS AND TURN AROUND AND GO
DOWN TO MAR-A-LAGO AND KISS HIS
RING AND COME BACK AND SIT
WITH -- IT JUST HURTS, YOU SAID.
YOU TOLD ME EARLIER IN THE BREAK
THAT YOU WERE LOOKING FOR -- YOU
GUYS WERE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT TO SAY.
YOU SAID MAYBE A BETTER WAY TO
SAY SOMETHING IS NOT TO SAY
ANYTHING AT ALL.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE WERE -- WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT SAYING
SOMETHING.
THEN WE SAID, NO, THE BEST WAY
IS TO JUST IGNORE THEM.
WE HAD NO IDEA IT WAS GOING TO
BLOW UP LIKE THIS.
WE REALLY DIDN'T.
I'M GLAD IT DID BECAUSE I THINK
IT MADE THEM THINK ABOUT WHAT
THEY DO.
JUST SITTING IN THE SENATORS'
OFFICERS AND LOOKING AT THE
PICTURES OF THEIR FAMILIES
BEHIND THEM AND THINKING, WHAT
DO THEY DO WHEN THEY GO HOME?
WHAT DO THEY SAY TO THEIR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN WHEN
THEY GO HOME?
WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY IS THIS
GOING TO BE?
>> IT TOOK COURAGE TO DO THAT.
WAS IT TOUGH TO DO?
>> HONESTLY AFTER WHAT WE'VE
BEEN THROUGH OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS, NO.
I DON'T HOLD RESPECT FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE NO INTEGRITY.
THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE.
IT'S AN INTEGRITY ISSUE.
THEY TOOK AN OATH TO UPHOLD THE
CONSTITUTION.
WHEN SOMEBODY CHALLENGES IT LIKE
TRUMP, THEY DO NOTHING.
THEIR SILENCE IS DEAFENING.
OR WORSE THEY PERPETRATE THE
SAME POLICIES AND LIES THAT
CAUSED THE INSURRECTION TO
HAPPEN.
>> I THINK IT WAS AN ABC
INTERVIEW RECENTLY WITH MITCH
McCONNELL AND HE JUST -- HE WAS
ASKED FOUR OR FIVE TIMES IN A
ROW SPECIFICALLY WILL YOU
SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP?
HE REFUSED -- EVERYTHING WAS
WISHY WASHY.
HE REFUSED TO SAY I DON'T
SUPPORT HIM.
WELL, YOU KNOW, THIS OR THAT,
BUT NEVER I'M AGAINST TRIBALISM.
I'M AGAINST YOU'RE ON MY TEAM OR
YOUR ON THIS TEAM.
WHEN SOMEBODY IS GOING TO BE THE
MOST POWERFUL PERSON IN THE
WORLD AND SAYS WE'LL PUSH THE
CONSTITUTION ASIDE OR I'M GOING
TO RIP IT UP, HOW DO YOU
SUPPORT -- HOW DO YOU EVEN
SAY -- THAT'S A NO BRAINER.
IT'S A NO, I'M NOT GOING TO
SUPPORT THEM.
>> LET'S TAKE A MOMENT TO
LISTEN -- McCARTHY WENT TO
MAR-A-LAGO TO SORT OF KISS THE
RING.
McCONNELL HAS NOT.
HE HAS BEEN CRITICAL OF TRUMP,
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT HE HASN'T
ANSWER THE QUESTION WHEN PUSHED.
HE ALSO HASN'T TALKED TO TRUMP.
LET'S LISTEN TO WHAT McCONNELL
SAID WHEN HE WAS ASKED ABOUT
THIS MOMENT.
HERE IT WAS.
>> I WOULD RESPOND BY SAYING
TODAY WE GAVE THE GOLD MEDAL TO
THE HEROS OF JANUARY 6th.
WE ADMIRE AND RESPECT THEM.
THEY LAID THEIR LIVES ON THE
LINE.
THAT'S WHY WE GAVE A GOLD MEDAL
TODAY TO THE HEROS OF JANUARY
6th.
>> DO YOU HAVE A MESSAGE FOR HIM
THIS MORNING, OR EITHER OF THEM
THIS MORNING?
>> I JUST DON'T KNOW HOW THEY
CAN STAND THERE AND TALK TO THE
PRESS, TALK TO THE CAMERAS AND
SAY WHAT THEY DO KNOWING WHAT
THEY'VE DONE IN THE PAST.
DO THEY THINK PEOPLE DON'T PAY
ATTENTION?
APPARENTLY A LOT DON'T PAY
ATTENTION, BUT -- I DON'T KNOW
IF THEY LOST CHILDREN IN A
INSURRECTION LIKE THIS, I WONDER
WHAT THEY WOULD DO.
>> THE PEOPLE WHO WERE THERE
FIGHTING ALSO RECEIVED AWARDS.
MICHAEL FANONE RECEIVED AN
AWARD.
HE SAID HE WAS HECKLED BY
MEMBERS OF HIS OWN POLICE
DEPARTMENT WHO CALLED HIM
DEROGATORY TERMS AND HE SAID
IT'S TOUGH FOR HIM TO DEAL WITH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT,
MEMBERS OF HIS OWN DEPARTMENT?
>> I HAD NO IDEA THAT HAPPENED
UNTIL ON THE WAY HOME FROM D.C.
YESTERDAY.
I HAD NO IDEA.
I THINK IT'S AWFUL.
I MEAN, HE PUT HIS LIFE ON THE
LINE.
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO DO THAT.
>> HE ALMOST MET THE SAME FATE
AS BRIAN.
>> HE ALMOST DIED.
HE WASN'T ASKED TO GO TO THE
CAPITAL.
HE PUT ON HIS UNIFORM AND WENT.
>> YOU BROUGHT UP THE
CONSTITUTION.
IT WAS THIS WEEKEND THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, DONALD TRUMP,
CALLED TO TERMINATE.
>> YOU MENTIONED THE
CONSTITUTION AS WELL.
>> BECAUSE BRIAN CAN'T BE HERE
TO SAY WHAT HE WENT TO WORK FOR
EVERY DAY, WHICH WAS TO DEFEND
IT WITH EVERYTHING HE HAD, WHAT
DO YOU THINK HE WOULD SAY?
>> I MEAN --
>> ABOUT THIS MOMENT IN AMERICA.
>> HE WOULD HAVE BEEN APPALLED.
YOU KNOW, IT'S -- WE HAVE 200
PLUS YEAR HISTORY OF -- WE HAVE
BAD MOMENTS, OF COURSE, THROUGH
HISTORY.
WE'VE GOTTEN THROUGH MANY OF
THEM, BUT NOW WE SEEM TO BE
GOING THROUGH MORE.
HOW DO YOU GO THROUGH THAT?
EVERY ELECTION LOOKS LIKE IT'S
GOING TO BE CHALLENGED.
WHAT'S THE REASON FOR IT?
I UNDERSTAND IF THERE'S AN
ELECTION THAT MIGHT BE CLOSE.
DO A RECOUNT.
TWO YEARS LATER AFTER EVERY
CONTESTED ELECTION WAS LOOKED AT
AND THEY FOUND LITTLE TO NO
FRAUD OR ABUSE OF THE SYSTEM,
YET EVERYTHING PERPETRATES.
THAT'S NOT OUR SYSTEM.
>> HONESTLY, I DON'T KNOW IF I
CAN SPEAK FOR BRIAN.
HIS OPINION WAS DIFFERENT BEFORE
HE DIED.
HE WAS A STAUNCH SUPPORTER, BUT,
YOU KNOW, TO HAVE -- TO INCITE
AMERICANS TO ATTACK OTHER
AMERICANS, IT'S MIND BOGGLING.
>> TALKING TO THESE POLICE
OFFICERS, PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
HOW BAD IT WAS IN THE CAPITAL
AND WHAT THESE PEOPLE LEFT IN
THEIR -- WHAT THEY DID TO THE
CAPITAL, THEY'RE STILL CLEANING
IT UP.
>> WE'RE SO GLAD YOU ALL CAN BE
HERE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT YOU'RE
DEALING WITH.
I KNOW Y